[Music]
when you think of Archimedes Eureka
moment you probably think of this as it
turns out it may have been more like
this in the 3rd century BC Hiram king of
the Sicilian city of Syracuse chose
Archimedes to supervise an engineering
project of unprecedented scale hi Ron
commissioned a sailing vessel 50 times
bigger than a standard ancient warship
named the siracusa after his City hi Ron
wanted to construct the largest ship
ever which was destined to be given as a
present for Egypt's ruler Ptolemy but
could have both the size of a palace
possibly float in Archimedes day no one
had attempted anything like this it was
like asking can a mountain fly King hi
Ron had a lot riding on that question
hundreds of workmen were to labor for
years on constructing the siracusa out
of beams of pine and fir from mount etna
ropes from hemp grown in Spain and pitch
from France the top deck on which eight
watchtowers were to stand was to be
supported not by columns but by vast
wooden images of Atlas holding the world
on his shoulders on the ship's bow a
massive catapult would be able to fire
180 pound stone missiles for the
enjoyment of its passengers the ship was
to feature a flower lined promenade a
sheltered swimming pool and bathhouse
with heated water a library filled with
books and statues a temple to the
goddess Aphrodite and a gymnasium and
just to make things more difficult for
Archimedes hi Ron intended to pack the
vessel full of cargo 400 tons of grain
10,000 jars of pickled fish 74 tons of
drinking water and 600 tons of wool it
would have carried well over a thousand
people on board including 600 soldiers
and it housed 20 horses in separate
stalls to build something of this scale
only for that to sink on its maiden
voyage well let's just say that failure
wouldn't have been a pleasant option for
Archimedes so he took on the problem
will it sink perhaps he was sitting in
the bath house one day wondering how a
heavy bathtub can float when inspiration
came to him an object partially immersed
in a fluid is buoyed up by a force equal
to the weight of the fluid displaced by
the object in other words if a 2000 ton
Siragusa displaced exactly 2,000 tons of
water it would just barely float if it
displaced 4000 tons of water it would
float with no problem of course if it
only displaced 1,000 tons of water well
Chiron wouldn't be too happy this is the
law of buoyancy and engineers still call
it Archimedes principle it explains why
a steel super tanker can float as easily
as a wooden rowboat or a bathtub if the
weight of water displaced by the vessel
below the keel is equivalent to the
vessels weight whatever is above the
keel will remain afloat above the
waterline this sounds a lot like another
story involving Archimedes and a bathtub
and it's possible that's because they're
actually the same story twisted by the
vagaries of history the classical story
of Archimedes Eureka and subsequent
streak through the streets centers
around a crown or Corona in Latin at the
core of the Syracuse iya story is a keel
or Corona in Greek could one have been
mixed up for the other we may never know
on the day the Syracuse iya arrived in
Egypt on its first and only voyage we
can only imagine how residents of
Alexandria throng to the harbor to
marvel at the arrival of this majestic
floating castle this extraordinary
vessel was the Titanic of the ancient
world except without the sinking thanks
to our pal Archimedes
[Music]